ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen minecraft
fällt meine lieben freunde ich würde
sagen wir gehen erst mal nach unten denn
wie nervt ein bisschen ich würde sagen
wir starten die heutige episode direkt
mit einem richtig geilen tipp die mir
der liebe leo unten in die kommentare
geschrieben hat danke dir auf jeden fall
da will ich versuche mich in der
heutigen folge ein bisschen dran zu
halten allerdings seht ihr schon dass
ich hier einiges gerade am abbauen bin
von unserer insel und dieser baum der
lupo baum auch dieser baum muss leider
vorerst für diese heutige folge erst mal
gefällt werden denn und das habe ich ja
schon in der letzten episode von diesem
projekt bereits gesagt und auch machen
wollen ich baue heute ein haus für den
willen christlich die laterne und die
kette hier kommt natürlich auch noch ab
das wird nachher alles natürlich wieder
aufgebaut die sache ist allerdings dass
ich platz brauche für das haus vom
villiger je sah ich frag mich ob der
wille
ich frag mich ob der will ja wieder gibt
uns die das marketing mal kurz mal
papier so meiser ich geb dir mal kurz
ein bisschen papier dann kann ich mir
nämlich noch zwei neue smaragde holen
und wir leveln hin weiter hoch hatte
schaaf er hat mich seit folgen nicht
angeguckt und hier fordern wir auch noch
zuckerrohr das werde ich jetzt auch mal
abbauen und ihr seht auch schon ich
fände es nicht wie sonst immer auf der
höhe 2 ab sondern wirklich ganz unten
und bauer es dementsprechend komplett ab
das liegt ganz einfach daran weil
scheiße das schaffen wir auch gar nicht
ich will mir nämlich eine unterirdische
zuckerrohr farben bauen und wo die
hinkommen wird erfahrt ihr auf jeden
fall im laufe dieser folge noch jedoch
mache ich das jetzt erst mal zu papier
und das papier können wir dann weiter
traden mit dem manager und ich nehme mir
auch mal glas mit ihr fragt euch jetzt
wahrscheinlich
ach ja niemand wird sich das jetzt
fragen ja sollen wir noch mal ein paar
smaragde geben zack zack acht stück
haben jetzt wieder bekommen
ich nehme das glas und baue damit hier
unten die schildkröteneier ein denn in
der letzten folge sind ja die
schildkröten eier gelegt worden und da
wurde mir geschrieben luca pass auf weil
zombies wollen die eier auch haben von
daher baue ich die eier die wir hier
haben und die bereits gelegt wurden
jetzt einfach mit glas ein damit wir
auch ein bisschen gucken was da so
vorgeht gucken können wann die teile
schlüpfen die haben einen ganzen apparat
jetzt auf jeden fall eingebaut um da
sollte nichts mit passieren
zudem können wir allerdings trotzdem
noch gucken ob da irgendwie was schlüpft
und wasser ja so schön sie
nicht aus allerdings erfüllt seinen
zweck es wird schon wieder dunkel sehe
ich gerade deswegen gehe ich mal ganz
schnell schlafen wieder extrem viel auf
der liste fürs heutige video meiner
lieben freunde denn was mir unter
anderem ich bau dir dein haus in der
heutigen folge aber du musst dich ein
bisschen gedulden mir wurde und in die
kommentare geschrieben dass ich einen
fehler bei den schatzkarten gemacht habe
und ich habe ja in der letzten folge
herausgefunden dass diese schatzkarte
eigentlich genau den gleichen umriss hat
wie diese schatzkarte und das
dementsprechend der gleiche chance ist
da wurde mir nämlich geschrieben was die
australischen eingeblendet habe das
jetzt mache ich meinen weg kaputt ich
habe wohl ein fehler begangen und die
beiden schatzkarten auf einmal geöffnet
und ich hätte erst den ersten schatz
finden müssen und dann hätte ich die
zweite schatzkarte aktivieren müssen
also schlussendlich verpassen wir als
einen schatz ich weiß nämlich den auf
eine andere art und weise irgendwie
wieder kriegen kann ich weiß noch gar
nicht ob ich gerade richtig fahren
das müsste die insel hier vorne sein
aber es sieht so aus als wenn der schatz
wieder im wasser ist irgendwo ich weiß
nicht warum ich immer so ein glück aber
auch pech mit den schätzen habe weil ich
einerseits natürlich relativ viele habe
auf der anderen seite sind die
allerdings immer an komischen orten ihr
freunde irgendwo unter wasser vielleicht
also genau hier soll er angeblich sein
ich hoffe immer noch dass wir irgendwann
mal diamanten oder sondern schatz haben
das wäre unnormal krass
wir haben den schatz freunde wir haben
den schatz gefunden
wir haben die truhe da unten ich werde
mich die schildkröten sind auch
mitgekommen
ich werde jetzt die schatztruhe öffnen
bitte da drin sind
ich werde auf der insel hier vorne jetzt
allerdings auch noch mal ein bisschen
holz mit dem das brauchen wir nämlich
alles für das haus was wir heute bauen
werten plus trommelwirbel schon richtig
meine lieben freunde wir machen heute
die insel reparatur und ich glaube auch
das wird ganz cool also natürlich hat
das haus für den dorfbewohnern erstmal
komplette priorität damit er nicht mehr
bei mir im bettchen pennt aber danach
kümmern wir uns auf jeden fall um die
insel reparatur da jetzt gerade die
sonne allerdings schon so ein bisschen
unter geht werde ich nur noch diesen
baum hier vorne mitnehmen und danach
schon wieder rüber fand unserer insel
ich bin schon echt stolz auf unsere
insel die mittlerweile also klar ein
anderen minecraft projekten da werden
die jetzt schon im netz und im portal
gewesen und keine ahnung was aber ich
bin wirklich froh bei auslandsprojekten
hier und es gibt ja nicht immer um
geschwindigkeit geht um technik nicht
nur um größere ein paar sekunden später
[Musik]
alles klar der gab meine schatzkarten
kann ich an der stelle jetzt auch
einfach wegschmeißen die brauche ich ja
nicht mehr
ich werde jetzt noch ein bisschen
sortieren und schlafengehen geht halt
nicht weil der typische vorne drin liegt
allerdings würde ich sagen wir sehen uns
jetzt wieder
ich mache euch eine time natürlich die
ganzen sachen für das haus zusammen
suche da ich unfassbar lange dafür
gebraucht aber die ganzen materialien
für das haus zu sammeln habe ich mal
wieder einen kleinen text vorbereitet
und ich finde sie zum lachen zu bringen
und zwar bei der lieben freunde haltet
euch fest schnallt euch an jetzt kommt
der knüller was passiert wenn man bei
ikea cloud
so wir sind ready to go das war jetzt
natürlich eine sehr lange time labs aber
ich habe auch richtig lange braucht die
ganzen sachen zu holen weil ich ja keine
fichtenholz bäume habe und deswegen
immer da hinten zu unserem truck and
fahren muss um die sachen zu holen
allerdings habe ich alles bekommen das
gute ist dass schaaf auch schon wieder
wolle dementsprechend kann ich auch ganz
kurz noch mal eben schnell ein kleines
scherchen hier mitnehmen denn wir
brauchen bereit betten in unserem
villiger haus das habe ich mir nämlich
gedacht weil ich in den kommentaren
gelesen haben das kann direkt wieder
vorne bekommen ich habe in den
kommentaren gelesen dass ich meine
villiger vermehren wenn ich denen betten
der einstelle und denen dann irgendwie
brot zu werfen oder irgendwie so ich hab
keine ahnung ob das wirklich klappt oder
ob ich wieder verarscht wurde allerdings
konzentriere ich mich jetzt erst mal
ganz kurz fürs bauen bis zum aufbauen
ich habe ein paar kommentare vorbereitet
bzw muss erst mal gucken was jetzt hier
so ok der macht direkt den ganz kann
sein dass alle tiere auf krawall
gebürstet sind ich habe ein paar
kommentare auf die ich gerne eingehen
möchte im heutigen video ich habe ein
paar fragen rausgesucht dann ist es eine
ganz entspannte atmosphäre allerdings
muss ich mich erst mal ein bisschen
konzentrieren gerade denn ich habe das
natürlich wieder im creative modus bei
mir in einer test welt vorbereitet wie
ich das ganze bauen will und ich glaube
es wird schlussendlich wirklich echt
beschissen aus dem zunächst einmal
müssen wir allerdings hier alles ein
bisschen weiter bauen denn der wille da
braucht natürlich ein großes haus damit
er sich auch wohl fühlte ja aber hier
ist ja auch schön der wahl
hier auf jeden fall mal so ein bisschen
und das spielt ja schon so ein bisschen
in die insel java
ich mach das gerade hier vorne auch noch
erde hinweg
warum gilt wie überall aber nicht bei
mir vorne machen da auch noch ein
bisschen erde hin zack zack und hier
natürlich auch wieder alles zu bauen
damit wir hier nicht irgendwelche
hohlräume haben wo man warum geht es
schon wieder nacht das tier vorne wird
auf jeden fall der eingang von dem
kleinen häuschen da können wir jetzt
schon mal von hier finde ich immer so
ein bisschen schöner die tür reinpacken
das ist eine fichtenholz tür ihr packe
ich so ein bisschen freude darauf dass
wir nicht auch ganz schön hier neben
hierhin packe ich die bauern die ich
gemacht habe die bruchsteinmauern und
dann kommen laternen drauf damit ihr
auch so einen schönen kleinen eingang
haben az wahnsinn und ich muss erstmal
kennen wir packen wir jetzt auf jeden
fall auch eichenstämme hin
ja das habe ich
ganz kurzes update zu unseren eiern da
gegen die nicht so richtig voran
die sind verletzt worden oder ich habe
keine ahnung ob ich das hier richtig
mache mit den eiern hier vorne geht
nichts voran bei diesem kleinen knubbel
wir heute absolut gar nicht mehr mit
euch und konzentriere mich jetzt einfach
nur noch auf den hausbau hier müssen wir
das ganze dann anscheinend wirklich noch
ein bisschen erweitern weil das doch
hier sechs blöcke werden müssen ein zwei
drei vier fünf der sechs bekommt ihr hin
hier kommt dann bedenkt ist falsch
gesetzt ich bin so ein solider 3 in die
höhe dann hier auch wieder ein 2 3 in
die richtung auch wieder drei in die
höhe
und dann hier auch wieder 123456 da
gehen wir jetzt auch wieder mit der axt
mit rechtsklick dran weil das hier alles
dieser entwendeten werden sollen das
finde ich eigentlich ganz schön zack
zack
hier kommen wir noch mehr hinein zwei
hier oben auch wieder sechs dran bamba
ich glaube das ist eine ziemlich
langweilige folge heute wo vielleicht
ich dafür nicht meine eisenachs nehmen
sollen hier vorne den rest auch noch
entrinden dann kommen wir nun ein
bisschen sogar schon zu jahr zu
dekoration und zwar kommen hier so
fenster leben dran die habe ich auch aus
dem fichtenholz gemacht daneben kommen
so kleine knöpfchen dran und hier kommen
jetzt glasscheiben rein plus eichenlaub
das finde ich immer ganz schön das hab
ich habe in meinem haus auch gemacht
dass das hier so ein bisschen grün ist
sie dann die glasscheiben rein das
gleiche machen jetzt auch noch von der
anderen seite eben und die fensterläden
lka falltüren und hier auch die beiden
knöpfe hierhin packe ich dann auch
wieder genauso wie es vorne gemacht habe
die stufen beziehungsweise die treppen
das bin ich auch ganz schön und dann da
die zäune drauf das ganze das ganze so
ein bisschen du stehst die ganze zeit in
einer schutzhülle und eine michael
jackson tanzen gar nichts sagen hier
vorne gehen wir dann auf jeden fall mit
der erde so ein bisschen runter das
sieht jetzt natürlich alles ein bisschen
näher nach scheiße aus allerdings sobald
das dingen zu wächst das gras drauf ex
chris g danke
ich weiß dass das schildkröteneier sind
hier vorne kommt dann auch noch mal das
eichenlaub vor hier ein zaun hin und
hier machen wir dann weiter mit den
entwendeten baumstämmen die kommen
nämlich hier so hin hier dann auch ein
kleines glas fenster rein dann nehmen
wir uns die aktion machen die auch so
von innen gut er braucht noch im boden
dann nehme ich hier jetzt einfach mal
bruchstein und packe den hier als boden
rein dann habe ich mir gedacht dass wir
hier so santoro vormachen das ist echt
ganz schön aus hier kommen gleich noch
treppen oder das kann ich auch mal kurz
andeuten hier die kommen nämlich so und
auf der anderen seite auch da kommt
natürlich auch noch ein bächlein drauf
es ist noch immer nicht fertig hier
kommt dann auf jeden fall das dach so
ein bisschen dran das ist geben wir mit
einem heber das gleich machen wir auf
der einen seite jetzt auch noch mal eben
schnell ich hab mir gerade schon so eine
kleine treppe gebaut damit er gleich ein
bisschen besser hoch das ist schon
wieder falsch echt bau kurz gedacht das
ist ein bisschen anstrengen dann sehen
wir sofort wieder leute ich hab neuen
witz wie nennt man ein veganer mit
durchfall movie maker
so ich fahre nur mal eben kurz die
treppe an der seite ab das dach ist
jetzt auf jeden fall fertig ist ein
bisschen aus wie so ein kleines wikinger
habe ich mich ein bisschen daran
orientiert hat mir natürlich auch
selbstverständlich wieder videos dazu
angeguckt so sieht das ganze ist auf
jeden fall von der seite aus so siehts
von hinten aus ich kann mal kurz runter
gehen dann seht ihr dass sich da oben
sieht man jetzt nicht so richtig aber
habe ich auch noch so ein glas hinein
gebaut das kann man von innen auf jeden
fall ein bisschen besser erkennen ich
gehe jetzt mal ganz kurz rein wir müssen
natürlich drinnen hier auch noch alles
ein bisschen schöner machen das will der
typ natürlich der wille der will hier
drin leben der will hier drin aber auch
mit seiner familie sich vernünftig
vermehren können deswegen habe ich zwei
betten direkt gemacht die ich hier
hinstellen kann hier kommen auf jeden
fall die fässer hin dann nehmen wir uns
im dichten holzzaun packen denen hier
hin und hier dann sieht das so ein
bisschen aus als wenn er sich auf der
werkbank die hier vorne hin kommt und
auf dem hof in denen ich hier vorne
direkt neben die tür stellen möchte als
wenn er sich da ein bisschen drauf an
lehnt den kartografisch packe ich
hierhin hier vorne auch noch seine
werkbank dann hier eine laterne drauf
ein blumentopf oder den habe ich auch
nicht und sport dem eisen sondern geht
auch ein bisschen schlecht deswegen
werde ich da auf jeden fall auch eisen
nehmen und ihnen damit heilen dass mit
mir auch unten die kommentare
geschrieben
ich habe hier noch ein zwei drei und
dann kann ich auch eine blume nehmen die
wir uns ja auf unserer kleinen
expeditionsteam wüsten dorf geholt haben
von daher erstmal runter zum symbol der
muss war mir ein bisschen zu viele
hobbys wir klicken hier mit rechts drauf
und deswegen ist er jetzt wieder fit und
hier vorne rein kommt dann
selbstverständlich auf den kartographie
tisch der kleine blumentopf zusammen mit
der kornblume dann sieht dass sie schon
mal so aus hier habe ich mir doch
überlegt dass sich die rollläden hier
sondern bisschen so mache bzw
dass das so ein bisschen abgetrennt
aussieht und hier
hier darf glaube ich gar nichts hin weil
er den platz brauchen oder das ist es
dann allerdings auch schon meine freunde
unser dorfbewohner haus ich finde es
eigentlich ganz süß ganz gemütlich mir
wurde geschrieben dass die dorfbewohner
beziehen wir sind der dorfbewohner auch
ihr brot braucht um sich zu freuen sich
unser dorfbewohner vermehren wenn ich
nur einen haben noch einen dorfbewohner
holen steht auf der liste für die
nächste folge unter der stelle will ich
die heutige episode minecraft mit luca
dann auch beenden meine lieben freunde
ich setze hier vorne doch mal eben so
ein bisschen was grünes hin hier vorne
beispielsweise einen baum hier so ein
bisschen auf den boden damit so ein
bisschen verruchte aussieht hier vorne
können wir auch noch ein kleines bäume
leiden hinsetzen zack zack zack zack
zack zack zack zack zack auf den boden
dann sieht so ein bisschen süßer in der
natur aus einem in der nächsten folge
holen und seinem zweiten dorfbewohner
dann können die sich paaren dann haben
die hier auf jeden fall platz dann
schmeiß ich mir auch ein bisschen brot
zu ich werde auf jeden fall in der
nächsten folge auch noch ein bisschen
der insel reparatur machen das hat mir
heute nicht so richtig mehr geschafft
aber meine lieben freunde wenn es euch
gefallen hat der lask gerne einen daumen
hoch unter dem video hier da abonniert
main kanal falls doch kein teil der
usaid und die neue episode minecraft mit
luca nicht verpassen wollte kommt
nämlich morgen online um 20 uhr da sehen
wir uns wieder
[Musik]